MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture,
we are going to start
looking at an example
of the QED process,
for which we can now, with
all the tools we have in hand,
calculate the matrix elements'
transition amplitude.
All right.
In more general terms, we
can look at all the examples.
And they are listed here--
second-order processes and
one third-order process.
We are going to discuss them
in more detail as we go along.
This is really just to
give you some feedback
for the different
kinds of processes
we're going to look at.
So the first one is
elastic scattering.
And muon-electron
scattering, that's
the one process we're going
to look in more detail.
Why?
Because this is
the simplest case.
For this process, there is
only one leading-order diagram,
which is exactly
the one shown here.
For other processes where have
the same particle interacting,
we find that we do have to
consider multiple diagrams--
for example, this one here,
where we have electron
and electron scattering.
And so we have to calculate
not just this leading diagram,
which looks exactly like the
one for the muon scattering,
but we also have to
include the [INAUDIBLE]
where we change the
outgoing electron leg.
And so on.
And other processes
are including
electron-positron
scattering, which
is caused Bhabha scattering,
Compton scattering, which
we discussed the
kinematics for already,
but also inelastic processes
like pair annihilation or pair
production.
There's a very
interesting diagram here,
which is the third-order
diagram, which
is responsible for the
anomalous magnetic moment.
And we'll talk more
about that when
we talk about
higher-order interactions.
So let's have a look at this
electron-muon scattering
process.
So only one diagram contributes
at the second order.
And so you have an electron
and a muon scattering
via the exchange of a photon.
This is after all
of QED diagram.
So now, how do we calculate
the matrix element?
We simply just follow
the Feynman rules--
Feynman rules as we
discussed them before.
And if you want to do this now,
you draw your Feynman diagram.
It's always very good and useful
to draw a Feynman diagram first
and label accordingly.
That's super-useful if you
want to systematically evaluate
this process.
And then you start going
backwards from an outgoing leg
back to the initial leg.
And you see this part here.
You have the u3, the
third particle here,
the vertex vector, and
the first particle.
Then you have a propagator
here for your photon.
It's given by minus i g
mu,nu divided by q square.
And then you analyze
the second part here.
Here you find the first
particle, vertex vector,
and the second particle.
For each of those
lines, you have
to make sure that
energy and momentum is
converted into those
[INAUDIBLE] delta functions.
And then the last
part you have to do,
integrate over your momentum.
All right.
That's already the end.
The next step in
your list of rules
is carry out the integration.
Integrate over q.
That drops your delta
function, but you
are left with one delta
function which you are also
supposed to drop, which then
gives you your matrix element.
Now, here we're already done.
If you now further want
to evaluate this diagram,
you actually have to be more
explicit about the spinors
involved.
What needs to be done
now is have a discussion
on how to handle the
spin of the particles,
meaning being explicit
about the spinors.
And in order to do
that, we'll discuss
how we treat spin, how
we have to treat spin,
either in an experiment
where the spin
of the initial particle is
known or an experiment where
we have to average over
all possible spin states.
So that's part of the
next lecture discussion.